Guys, I don't think we should have to say this, but if you're using freaking gift cards or some
other shit, just, I'm not even going to go into that, but like you should be smart enough to know
that's not a good idea. I mean, think about it like this. If one of your clients said, Hey,
can I put this, uh, this gift card on your Stripe account? You'd say, hell no. Because then what
happens next month when it declines, I got to chase you down. You think Google's any different
except for they're, uh, uh, worth 500 billion times more than you and I combined. Like,
of course not. So just be smart as far as like, put yourself in their shoes. You do the same
damn thing as them. I would, I'd suspend everyone's ass and say, well, it's what I'm doing, right?
Like everyone, like, I don't just give you the application to this program. I'm like, go find
fucking thing. And, and, and if you really want to get in, you'll bug me about it. Right? Like I want
people that are serious. And that's what happens when you, you have something like it's like Google
guys back to the law of control, right? The person that cares the least or appears to care
least has all the control. Google has what we need. They have this platform called Google ads.
They do not need our money. They can get money from any, any, everybody else. So therefore they
have all the control and we have to abide by their freaking stupid ass rules. I don't like it any
more than you do, but again, I would do the same thing. So what I'm getting more than even just a
tactical is just like looking at this going, like just instead of treating it like, oh my gosh,
I'm such a victim. Look at it as like, Hey, everyone's going to deal with this. But instead
of me just like being so pissed off, I'm going to master this suspension thing. Because if this has
happened to me, it's probably a problem with multiple people and there's an opportunity there
to help. And so it's like, that's exactly what Jeff did. And now it's like, okay, this is,
this is interesting because he has the skillset and this knowledge that he has acquired by going
through the thing. So just change your mindset of like, it sucks. I get it. But guess what?
It is, it is what it is. It is what it is. It's part of the business. It's a very small and
significant thing. And some of you guys that are freaking out about it, it's like, I just question
how the hell you were raised because like that, if this is throwing you off that bad,
I don't know how you guys coped with stress. Like I've really,
it's, it's wild anyway, but we're talking about a very small subset of people.
I think that's true too. Like just like you said, it's going to happen. It's going to happen to you
again. It's going to happen to me again. At the same time, like, you know, this isn't everybody's
having these issues. So as far as the training goes, like, you know, follow the training,
do what's there. And it could be like your fifth website that gets a flag on it. Like it's not,
it's not necessarily like, if you don't do this, don't like take the action. It's okay.